〔※非公式の字幕です〕
ウウッ！
やっぱ 料理するっつったら やっぱ⇒
（BGM：サンバ風）♪♪～
見た目から入らなきゃいけないからね。
やっぱ 格好はこれでいきましょう。
（BGM：サンバ風）♪♪～
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
お前ら。男のモテる…。
♪♪～
条件。なにか分かるか？
そう！ 料理が出来るか 出来ないか でござる。
♪♪～
知っての通り 僕はですね⇒
自炊を 全然しないんですけど も！
♪♪～
ちょっと キッチン…。
（「ガタッ」）
イタッ。
ちょっと キッチンが大きくなったんで。
♪♪～
きょうは！ 自炊で！ なにか作ってみようかと思います。
僕の作る料理は もう メチャクチャなので⇒
♪♪～
ひょっとしたらね…。
マネして 食中毒になられるの 困るので⇒
♪♪～
ま くれぐれも マネしないでくれ。
おいしく出来たらマネしていいけどもね。
♪♪～
という訳で えっと ちょっと ホントに⇒
なんにも分かんないんですけども⇒
♪♪～
とりあえず料理を作ってみようと思います。
レシピとかもなにも見ずに⇒
♪♪～
もう とりあえずね なんか…⇒
テキトウに… 材料っぽいのがあるんで。
♪♪～
ちょっと 感覚でね ちょっと 料理 作ってみようと思います。
では 行こう！
（「ガチャン」）
（SE：「ピュピュン」）
<<<用意するものはこちら！>>>
<<<ハム！>>>
<<<玉ねぎ！>>>
<<<卵！>>>
<<<ケチャップ！>>>
<<<トマトソース！>>>
<<<塩コショウ！>>>
まずは 玉ねぎの皮を剥きます。
（BGM：ハーモニカ風 ローテンポ）♪♪～
玉ねぎ…。
ウエッ ヤッヴァッ。…
玉ねぎ。ほいっ！
（BGM：ハーモニカ風 ローテンポ）♪♪～
ちょっと 泥が付いてそうだから。
♪♪～
まず ちょ… 水で洗います。
泥が付いてるかもしんないからね。
♪♪～
で 水で洗ったあと…。
せっせと こう… 皮を剥いてあげましょう。
♪♪～
玉ねぎは この なんか⇒
上と下が 毒を持ってるって聞いた事があるから⇒
♪♪～
ここはね 食べちゃダメなんですよ。
誰かが言ってた。
♪♪～
これはね ダメなんだよ。
これは食べちゃダメです。
♪♪～
危ないんで こういうのはやめましょう。
（「ドンッ」）
多分 これくらい剥ければいいと思います。
♪♪～
こうやって玉ねぎを剥いてるあいだに⇒
もう もうね フライパンを熱しましょう。
♪♪～
フライパンもね 焦げると… あぶってくその前には（？）⇒
ちゃんと洗わなきゃ。ちゃんと水でね⇒
♪♪～
こう ちゃんと洗ってからね ＠％＊いきます。
これで バッチリ綺麗になった。
♪♪～
このフライパンに… このまま熱すると危ないから⇒
ちょっとだけね サラダ油〔あぶら〕を足す訳っスよ。
♪♪～
こうする事によって こう… もし 何かを焼く事になっても⇒
なんか こうね…。焦げにくくなるっていうね⇒
♪♪～
そういう性質があるんスよ 油には。
覚えとけっ！
じゃあ まずフライパンを熱しましょう。
♪♪～
（「ガチャッ」）
（点火する音）
♪♪～
あ 来た 来た…。よし いいぞ。
いいぞ。
♪♪～
（「ジューー…」）
えっ ジュージュー 言ってる。待て 待て。
…早まるな。
（「ジューー…」）
まあ これで フライパンは よしとしよう。
♪♪～
（「ジューー…」）
で この フライパンが熱されてるあいだに⇒
♪♪～
俺は 玉ねぎをみじん切りにします。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
よし。
♪♪～
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
バカ。なんで なんで なんで？
（BGM：倍速）♪♪～
なんで なんで？ ちょ 待て。
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
（BGM：倍速）♪♪～
アツッ!! 待って おい 待て。
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
（BGM：倍速）♪♪～
待って 待って。危ないぞ。
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
♪♪～
おっ おい！ なんでだ？
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
♪♪～
ハァ!?
（「パチパチ…」と油が跳ねる音）
♪♪～
アァ!! なんで バチバチ 言う？
（音が収まっていく）
♪♪～
俺の知ってる油は バチバチ鳴らないよ。
弱火で… 弱火で フライパンをとりあえず この… 熱しておきましょう。
（BGM：等倍速）♪♪～
（「ドン！ ドン！」）
いいぞ。…うぅ あぶねぇ。
玉ねぎをなるべく細かく切ります。
（BGM：等倍速）♪♪～
ちょっと多過ぎたかなぁ？
♪♪～
玉ねぎは…。
ちょびっとでいいです。
やべっ なんか… えっ なんか すごい事になってる。
おい… 急げ お前ら。
（BGM：倍速）♪♪～
で で で えっと…。
玉ねぎは もう こんな感じです。
（BGM：倍速）♪♪～
玉ねぎは ちゃんとみじん切りに出来たら もう これでいいんスよ。
玉ねぎはもう こんな感じでいいと思います。
♪♪～
な… もうちょっと 細かくしなきゃいけない。
まず とりあえず玉ねぎをフライパンに入れましょう。
♪♪～
（「ジュー…」）
ウッ。なんか 焦げてね？
なんで？ なんか 焦げてる。
（「ジュー…」）
俺の知らないトコでなにかが起きてる。
（フライ返しでフライパンをこする音）
待って 待って なんか 焦げてね？
何 この焦げ？
ちょっと おかしいな。きょう 調子 悪いわ。
（「ジューーー!!」）
ワァーーッ!!
（BGM：『カルメン』）♪♪～
ワワワ… ビックリした。
ヤバイ… 換気扇 換気扇。
（BGM：『カルメン』）♪♪～
あぶねぇ あぶねぇ。お前ら 気を付けろ マジ。
え 煙〔けむ〕くね？ すいません ちょっと トラブっちゃいましたね。
じゃあ もう一回 気を取り直していきましょう。
（BGM：元の物 等倍速）♪♪～
なんか なんでサラダ油が⇒
なんか あんなのになったか 俺にはわからない。
（BGM：元の物 等倍速）♪♪～
やっぱ 料理は奥が深いね。
♪♪～
よし 今回は 多分いい感じです。
よし じゃあ これを 早速 セッティング。
♪♪～
オッケ。で！ 先ほどみじん切りにした⇒
玉ねぎを ファイア。
♪♪～
更に ハムを…。
ちょっと 大きいな。切ってあげよう。
ちょっと 大きいので切ってあげましょう。出来ました。
♪♪～
で ハムも ちょっと細かめに切って⇒
このままブチ込みます。
♪♪～
オッケ。こんな感じです。
これで もう だいぶ ゲストは揃いました。
♪♪～
（「ジューー…」）
う… いいよー。
で このままだと 味〔あじ〕っ気〔け〕が無いので⇒
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
ここで 塩コショウ ブチ込みます。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
あ… これはヤベェ。これ 来てる。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
あぁ いいよ～。で ここで⇒
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
玉ねぎ 投入します。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
おし。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
なるべく 卵は こう… なんか⇒
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
グジャグジャッってして下さい。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
スクランブルエッグみたいな感じです。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
卵 もう１個 行きましょう。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
味付けに コーラを入れましょう。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
コーラを ちょびっと入れる事で 全く 味が変わります。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
あぁ ちょっと 入れすぎちゃった。
（「ジューー…」）
微妙な甘さが おいしさの引き立て役になります。
♪♪～
よし だいぶ 来たぞ。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
更に！ ここで 隠し味です。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
『トマト＆ガーリック』〔…ｱﾝﾄﾞ…〕。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
ここで トマトソースをちょびっと入れましょう。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
よし。これで 加熱作業は終了。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
もう なんか なにすればいいか分かんないし⇒
（「ジューー…」）
頭から 卵 降って来る。
なんか これ でも いい感じだぞ。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
塩コショウ ちょっと 付け足し… 付け足しましょう。
（「ジューー…」）
♪♪～
ワァァー!!
（「ドンッ！」）
ちょ… 分かんない。俺 なん… なに 作ってんだろうなぁ。
じゃ これに 更に あとは ごはんを作ります。
♪♪～
便利な世の中だな。
早速！ 出来た物を皿に移しましょう。
♪♪～
え これ 割と うまそうな気がするなぁ。
ただのスクランブルエッグに見えてきたなぁ。
ここで… ケチャップを掛けましょう。
♪♪～
（「ドンッ バタッ」）
出来た。
♪♪～
エヘヘ…。
出来るじゃん 俺。
♪♪～
もう１個 欲しいトコだ。
（「チ～ン」）
♪♪～
なんか ばあちゃんちの匂いがする。
これを 別々に食うんじゃなくて⇒
♪♪～
これ 混ぜて かん… 完成なんスよね。
この ごはん 今 作ったんですけど も！
♪♪～
この さっき作った⇒
はじめの 特製の…⇒
♪♪～
料理を ブチ込みます。
これを ちょっと こう 混ぜ合わせます。
♪♪～
ちょっと待って。
…
これ オムライスじゃん。
（「パンッ！」）
はいっ！ 完成しました！
♪♪～
はじめしゃちょー 新生活の 初の！
手料理でございます。こちら！
♪♪～
粉々〔こなごな〕オムライスでーす。
（一人で拍手）
オムライスになるとは⇒
思ってなかった。
♪♪～
え 普通においしい！
ホントに 限りなくおいしい。
限りなくおいしいけど も！
オムライスです。